In the last demo, you can see that increasing tessellation can make lighting
computations look better. However, if you turn up the shininess, you can still
pick up problems. Also, along the edges of the sphere the density of the
triangles is much higher than the middle. If we keep increasing the sphere's
tessellation, we'll be making a huge number of triangles along the fringe, which
will cost us computation time without adding much to the final image. Ideally,
what we'd like to evaluate is the reflection model each pixel. This is an
entirely fine solution. Instead of interpolating the RGB values that result from
computing the effects of lighting, we interpolate anything we need in the
reflection model. In this case all we need to interpolate is the shading normal.
What this means on the GPU is that we have the vertex shader, we input the
position in normal as before. For output, we get the screen position and instead
of an RGB computed from the reflection equation, we put transformed normal on
the output. These two normals are the vertex normals, and they're interpolated
per pixel. This interpolated normal is input to the fragment shader, which then
evaluates the reflection model and computes the RGB to be displayed. I should
mention one important point with normal interpolation. The interpolated normals
will not be normalized. That is, their length will not all be one. As you can
see in this drawing, the interpolated normals are always a bit shorter when
interpolation occurs. So, each normal should be normalized before using it in
the lighting computation. When we interpolate normals and evaluate the
reflection model at each pixel, this is called per pixel shading or phong
shading. Confusingly, phong invented two cool things. One is the phong
reflection model, which gives us a spectral highlight, shiny spot. The other is
this phong shading, where we interpolate data across the triangle and compute
the color per pixel. This is compared with Gouraud shading, where the color is
computed at each vertex and is interpolated between those two. Try running the
new demo and see how phong shading vastly improves image quality. There's a
cost, of course, and that then the lighting calculations need to be performed
much more frequently. But this is often what you need if you want to have a good
specular highlight.